hi guys welcome back to part number two
with the interview with Matt's premise
and my a massive immersion right and we
talked about massive immersion if you
haven't watched the first part of the
video please do it's really interesting
we talked a lot about a lot about
immersion how to learn Japanese how to
learn languages mechanics and dynamics
of language learning kids versus adults
is really interesting don't miss part
number one now let's keep delving into
language learning massive immersion and
what not and the next question I have a
list of questions here is how do you get
used to the Japanese word order without
having to translate everything in your
head I myself try to learn Japanese some
nine years ago I do speak a little bit
but the main mistake that I've made was
that I was trying to speak Japanese from
the very beginning by translating
everything directly from from a native
language into Japanese and the the
sentences that I wanted to form were too
complex and the cognitive load on my
brain was huge so if I came to you let's
suppose you write Japanese consultant
and I came to you desperate after
failing at Japanese miserably what piece
of advice would you tell me to say look
I just go back and do it this way well
what what should I do to go back and try
to learn but not from a total beginners
perspective but from someone who has
learned a language maybe that with the
wrong approach and has to find a new
approach that gives them hope yeah yeah
so kind of like building off what we
were talking about in part one I like to
think about it as first learn how to
understand and once you can understand
then you can worry about speaking and in
a way you can just produce your
cognitive load of the whole process of
learning a language by making this
division and the way that I kind of
think about it is that when you're
learning to understand when I say
understand I mean understand in the way
that we understand our native language
right like right now anyone who's
watching this video you're probably
fluent enough in English where as soon
as the words that I'm speaking hit your
ear you've already understood them you
couldn't not understand them even if you
tried that's how automatic it is for you
and so to get to that point in
understanding basically it
what you have to do is build a machine
in your brain that essentially
translates your target language directly
into meaning and once you build this
very complicated machine you can almost
use the same machine to produce the
language you just have to reverse the
order so you start with meaning and it
will spit out Japanese and of course it
takes some practice to get it working
well and there you know more cow it's a
little bit more complicated than that
but that's how I think about it is build
the understanding machine and you can
use most of that that hardware to
translate the other way and so when we
talk about building that kind of
understanding machine I like to
reference these ideas the ideas of
stephen krashen even though I don't
think it's a perfect model I think his
idea of the input hypothesis which
essentially says that we acquire
language basically when we understand
messages in the language so even with
the Japanese word order right if you
knew that the word neckl means cat and
the word Edo means to exist in terms of
inanimate object and you were watching a
TV show where there was a cat on the
road and you see a kid point to the cat
and you're like Nikhil guy you do like
you would know oh he's saying there's a
cat and but you would hear oh the order
is actually cat there is instead of
there as a cat right but you wouldn't
have to consciously think about this
you're you would just it'd be very
intuitive right you can your brain can
draw the connection between Oh cat there
is and there's the cat well if you can
you know expose yourself to many
situations like this where you were able
to grasp it because it was simple enough
and there was the context then it would
start to become natural and your brain
would just get it after a while and then
you can move on to the next layer of
something more complicated like over
like oh look there's a cat over there or
something and so that's why I think oh
through immersion through finding you
know I like to use TV shows and things
like that for immersion because the
visuals can give you a lot of context to
infer what's being said and I think
ultimately it's fine if you're missing
let's say 90% of the dialogue if there's
10% of the dialogue that you can that is
accessible to you at least I prefer this
because I would rather watch a TV show
that's actually interesting to me even
if most of it if most of it's going over
my head then watching something that's
kind of designed for children or
designed for a learner but that's just
my personal preference if you prefer to
use material that's used for a learner
then I think that probably works just as
well it's mostly just important to what
it do whatever is most engaging to you
but the important thing is that you're
just understanding basic messages the
more messages you understand the more
natural intuitive it will become and
once you get to the point where you can
understand even very sophisticated
messages and I mean understand them
intuitively like you do for English then
it won't be that difficult for you to
kind of reverse engineer that process
and start with meaning and just think HM
how would a Japanese person say this
thing and as soon as you ask yourself
that question if you've exposed yourself
to a lot of Japanese things will just
start kind of popping up and that was
what the process of speaking was like
for me so it's really just a matter of
getting used to it through mass exposure
right but the problem I see the possible
problem is I don't know if you've met
people have this problem is that I was I
was talking to a friend of mine and we
agreed on the fact that the difficulty
in listening to a lot of Japanese
differently from other European
languages is that it's really tiring to
you know watch something with subtitles
in Japanese and then you got the
language I mean it's it's more tiring
than say just as an Italian it would be
to listen to Spanish because even if
let's say let's suppose that I don't
speak a word of Spanish I am taking
obviously a very easy case the Spanish
is a very closed language to Italian but
even a language such as German it it is
it has been easier for me to expose
myself to languages that are a little
bit more comprehensible but what
happened with me is that even if I use
language learning material for beginners
or for intermediate learners for that
matter it's really tiring it's time to
even even decode the the structure of a
sentence like the longer it gets the
more difficult because you have to look
at the end of the sentence and then you
have to go backward and realize you know
the different components so I if I got
it correctly you're able to you were
able and you're still able well not now
that you speak Japanese well but back in
the day you could spend two hours of a
TV show understanding maybe 10% but that
10% was really good for you and it was
very useful but don't you think that a
lot of people might find it difficult or
my finding discouraging to watch
or get exposed to something that they
barely understand that's that's the
problem that I've had before and and it
was a little bit discouraging even to go
through I don't know text to one page in
Japanese that's that's one of the
biggest obstacles for me so for just to
give an example I have here I could show
you like it I have a bunch of I don't
know if you probably you can't see it
from here but I have this do you see
this bonsai so this is a very cool this
is a very cool book that I found in even
text like this so you can this is for
intermediate learners now probably it
doesn't show very well in camera but
it's the interesting part is that it
talks about you know typical Japanese
staying sumo or traditions etc but to go
through one page it took me like it took
me two hours you know yeah and and so I
was wondering how you you've gotten past
that like it took you a lot of patience
what would you what advice would you
give to someone who says okay I want to
learn Japanese but I get you know
discouraged because truth be told the
attention span of madam what's going
down but what would you suggest or
suppose plow through it just try your
best stick to it because it's difficult
nowadays too yeah something it's
definitely difficult and I think what it
kind of sounds like is you're talking
about a pretty active form of learning
or engaging where you're throwing
sentence by sentence you're making sure
you understand it you're calm you're
contemplating the the syntax you're
looking up whatever words you didn't
know and I would do that as well but
maybe 30 minutes a day 30 minutes to an
hour a day and then the rest of the time
I was a consuming Japanese content with
a much more relaxed form of attention so
you know I would turn on a TV show
and I wouldn't necessarily make a that
much of a conscious effort to understand
I would more kind of let it wash over me
and what I found is that even when I
just completely let it wash over me I
without making any real conscious effort
to follow along there would still be
words that would pop out at me even when
I very first started you know you can
learn the most common 100 words in the
language and listen to Japanese for an
hour and you'll start hearing those
words pop out at you you might not
understand how they're functioning
within the sentence it might just be
like well assuming muscle oh but do
we'll still know oh that was that word
that was that word and this is where the
process really starts so at the
beginning it's gonna that's all your
brain is gonna be able to do is maybe
pick out a word here or there and it's
even not gonna be 100% accurate at that
so I just view that as well that's the
first process can you learn to start
picking out words in isolation and even
after a few weeks of listening you'll
get to the point where there might be a
hundred two hundred words that you can
effortlessly understand even when you're
really tired at the end of the day and
you're not paying attention you'll still
be able to pick up that word and once
you have those words down then there'll
be a new layer of words that kind of
start popping out at you that you can
start learning those as well and so
basically the way I think about it is
there's maybe a layer of competency you
have the language when you're putting in
zero effort and then there's a higher
level of ability you have when you're
putting in all of your conscious effort
and so maybe the average person tries to
start at that at that higher level where
they're focusing on how much they can
understand when they're putting in all
their effort and trying to push that
forward but yeah there's a limit of how
much you can do with that because we all
have a limited amount of mental energy
and that can be very taxing on your mind
right I would I would do that a little
bit a day but then I drop back down to
the level I could understand with almost
no effort and I'd still that arise and
eventually get to the point where what I
could understand with no effort was
where I used to be able to understand
with all my effort and then when that
happens the amount I can understand with
effort goes up even more so I think it's
more kind of changing your mindset to
almost how a child would approach
watching a TV show right like maybe you
can watch an infant be really entranced
watching some show like Blue's Clues and
you know they're kind of just taking it
in soaking it up they're not really
analyzing what's going on and I think
and they're not really getting upset
about what they're missing right they
just they're just whatever happens
that's cool well I think developing this
childlike mindset I called it tolerating
ambiguity being okay with the fact that
you're gonna miss stuff and that you
might only get a word here there and
this is very challenging for adults
because through the kind of education
that we have in the West were brought up
with the idea that understanding is very
important and if you don't understand
something that means that you're
incompetent or stupid and you you
shouldn't move on to the next thing
until you've mastered the first thing so
letting go of this mindset and taking a
more kind of organic type of mindset
that's just like what
whatever I understand that's cool
whatever I don't understand that's okay
I'll get it later you know and kind of
having faith in the in the process faith
in your brain that your brain will learn
at its own pace
with it you know its own sense of order
and how things work and so there's that
and also there's just the component of
building your endurance over time like
maybe at the beginning you can only
spend 15 minutes a day in Japanese
because after that your brain has just
had enough maybe you do that for a few
weeks and then try 20 minutes for the
week after that right and maybe tried 25
and also I'm a big fan of kind of
partially passive immersion where try to
throw on a Japanese podcast while you're
cooking and if you want you don't have
to try to pay attention to it you can
almost ignore it but part of your brain
will still be listening they'll still be
a few words you catch over here and
there and if things go well maybe you'll
even understand enough where you'll get
curious where you're like oh wait that
sounds familiar and I think kind of
igniting that curiosity is really
important because that's the that's a
form of motivation that's sustainable
it's getting curious and it's exciting
when you when you realize that you you
understood a word that you that you
learned yesterday or even when you
understood one whole sentence even if
that was the only sentence you
understood for that that half hour it's
still really cool and you're like whoa I
understood a real Japanese sentence and
a nice to understand it in Japanese with
no translation or anything so I think
it's yeah it's it's more of a mindset
shift I'm a big fan of when people talk
about either this or that in language or
new you remind me of a very important
point you said that you do some
deliberate practice in trying to decode
you used to do it try to decode it
attacks the etc but on top of that you
did also passive listening and I think I
think you can do both that you should do
both you should do as many you know
activities engaging as many activities
as you can passive listening will do in
the dishes or you know reading attacks
and trying to decode it that's as a
matter of fact it's not the only thing
that I did when I was trying to learn
Japanese but mostly I was trying to do
this theory deliberate stuff and and I
didn't engage in I didn't spend time
watching anime which is what I should
have done anyway so on to the next
question um what kind of listening
material is suitable for beginners so
it's imagine that someone comes along
and says Matt I'd like to learn Japanese
but I'd like to start by listening on
top of other things I also
start just by pure eliciting what kind
of materials do you have any platforms
or websites or material that you can
point to that is aimed at beginners
beginners that can understand Japanese
from context just from audio alone
without any English explanations yeah
well so personally I was very influenced
by the all Japanese all the time website
like I was talking about in part one and
part of his philosophy was to only use
content made by native speakers for
native speakers and I really took this
to heart he was kind of saying like from
day one think about whatever content you
want to consume after you're fluent and
start consuming that now yeah that was
what I what I did and that kind of was
how I was raised
um like in Japanese you could say and so
for a while I was really really believed
in this idea of oh no learning material
no that that's that's we're gonna be
slower in the long run but now I've kind
of more come around and realized that
this works well for some people but for
other people it's actually not it's just
really frustrating and it's overall it's
just not gonna be best for them and so
now I'm realizing that until you get to
kind of a low intermediate level for a
lot of people that probably is wiser to
use materials that are more tailored for
beginners because even though they might
not be as intrinsically exciting and
they might you know be have a little bit
of an artificial element to it there's a
real pragmatic purpose in that and it's
gonna help accelerate their process to
that level where they can be more
comfortable with native media but
because I personally didn't really take
that path and until more recently when I
cam came around to this idea I was still
not not really pushing those ideas I
don't have that much of a repertoire
that I can point to of like good
beginner material but what I did and and
so this this approach worked well for me
and works well for some other people so
I'm not saying this for everybody but
what can work well is like I I would
like to try to find TV shows that have a
visual component and ideally they'd be
something that are more kind of
down-to-earth like maybe a romance or a
comedy or just a slice-of-life something
that's not really fantasy or science
fiction because that's going to be
extremely difficult and what you can do
is either choose a show that you've
already watched once with English
subtitles or maybe you can choose
japanese dub or whatever your limit or
starting right a japanese dub of a show
that you've seen in english or maybe you
can even just choose a show but read a
summary of it on wikipedia or read the
episode summaries on netflix so you have
some idea what's going on and then you
watch it and just due to the visuals you
know like for a corny comedy show or
corny like romantic comedy so i mean you
could probably turn the volume off and
still basically get what's going on so
it's it's very comprehensible and so in
that sense you can still be entertained
even if you're missing a lot of the
language and there there'll be bits and
pieces where because you have an idea
what's going on it's easier to draw the
connection between what you studied and
what's going on right like you know if
you learned the word to run like Hachi
do and then there's some scene or some
random some guys running and maybe
someone says like not even though like
hey what are you running and then your
brain can what are you doing running
right now your brain can draw the
connection between like oh that guy was
running and that was that was the word
to run and so it can help you draw more
connections this way so my approach was
always to try to find something that's
interesting to you that you actually
like that's authentic but then also is
more approachable because it has a
visual element and then maybe read the
synopsis and then what I would do is I'd
actively watch it once and then I would
take the audio from it and then use that
audio as as the passive immersion so I'd
listened to it over and over again while
I was doing the dishes and things like
that because you know repetition can be
very helpful but it can also be tedious
so I found that getting in the
repetition while I was kind of
multitasking like walk exercising or
cleaning was a good way to do that and
then because I'd already watched it once
when at all the various scenes I could
visualize in my head what was happening
in that scene I could remember the
visuals and that would it was almost as
if I was watching it again and I could
see what was happening and so I've made
it really easy to learn from an easier
to engage because if you just take a
podcast you know you might have
literally no idea what's going on
fantastic okay let's get a little bit
more technical now let's talk about
learning vocab learning srs systems of
memory how you use remember to revoke
ab-about grammar patterns and about
kanji so let's start with vocab do you
use a key you know on key for those who
don't know it as food
no the system is a flashcard based
system flashcards are at least like you
know cards where you can see say word
and Japanese or a sentence in Japanese
and then in English if you're native
English speaker and then you can just
take a look at the party in English and
try to remember in Japanese and I'm Kia
is a software that basically takes care
of presenting these cards that's well
first well I'll let you speak was is
what is space-time repetition what is on
key I just introduce it myself but if
you use it if you recommend it and what
do you do - remember vocab in general
when it comes to you know acquiring
vocab be it on paper or dude when you're
watching something when you're listening
to something what how do you learn words
you know yeah and so I was a very heavy
Anki user like probably put many
thousands of hours into that program and
it worked really well for me so yeah so
Anki is this basically electronic
flashcard system where you can either
download pre-made sets of flashcards
that were made by other people or you
can make your own flashcards manually
and then unki essentially tries to show
you their flashcards right before you
forget them so that you can strengthen
your memories as optimally as possible
with without doing any unnecessary
reviewing and so I think it's a really
good way to learn vocabulary because
it's just very straightforward it
basically handles the knowledge for you
so you don't have to worry about when
you should review and and it kind of
solves the problem of how do you not
forget what you've already learned as
you continue to learn new things because
if you take a class in the language you
know every week you might learn ten new
words but then by week three you're
starting to forget the words you learn
on week one because you haven't been
reviewing them and people try to manage
this with paper notebooks and have their
own few systems but it can get very
complicated very quickly so having this
very simple form of artificial
intelligent artificial intelligence
basically tell you when to review your
cards is it's very practical especially
when combined with lots of exposure to
the language because I think one issue
people run into is that they they learn
about this program monkey they learn
about how it can help them learn a lot
very quickly and then they basically
just go balls to the wall learning
50 words a day with Anki many hours on
the program but that's all they do and
they don't actually spend time consuming
real authentic content in the language
and so they just end up with a lot of
knowledge but none of it is activated
and so it doesn't really do any good to
them and that's why people end up
quitting the program or writing it off
is not effective but I think it's
important to combine the immersion
component with the learning component
and so the way that I would do that is
well if you're a very beginner I think
it can be useful to just download a deck
that can help you learn the most common
1,000 2,000 words because you know the
most common few thousand words covers
almost 80% of the entire spoken language
so just kind of nailing those out
memorizing those can give you a really
good head start but then after that
rather than using some kind of
vocabulary list to choose what words you
learn I like to actually decide what
words to learn from my immersion itself
so what I'll do is like what I used to
do is I would watch anime Japanese anime
with Japanese subtitles and I would wait
for a sentence to pop up where I
understood everything but one word in
that sentence and then I'd look up that
word in a dictionary and if that was
enough for me to kind of have the aha
moment of what the senate's meant as a
whole then I'd make a flashcard and Anki
that had that sentence on the front the
whole sentence and then the definition
of the word I didn't know on the back
and so the reason why this is useful is
because it's a lot more natural for the
brain to understand a sentence than to
try to understand an isolated word and
because this word came from something I
was actually watching I know the context
I know which character said it who they
were saying it to and so it already has
a lot of connections inside of my brain
and it just makes it a lot easier to
kind of consume it more and more
naturally and so I would make maybe 10
to 15 of these cards every day and it
was a good way to just integrate my
immersion with the more conscious
studying and then once I knew maybe four
thousand three four thousand words I
started to use a Japanese - Japanese
dictionary when I would do this so
instead of looking up the word I didn't
know in the Japanese to English
dictionary I would look it up in a
Japanese - Japanese dictionary and put
that definition on the back of my card
and if there was a word I didn't know in
the definition then I'd learned those
words as well in Anki
and so through doing this I was able to
over the course of a couple years you
know learn almost 20,000 words and get
to the point where I could read novels
and things like that no problem because
it you know the Anki tells you when to
review so that you don't forget and it
worked very well so I would learn like
ten words every single day review maybe
seventy to eighty and because you're the
intervals of how often you have to
review a card to keep it in your memory
grow exponentially the total amount of
review doesn't really increase over time
it stays pretty consistent even though
you continue to learn and and learn and
what I found was that making a flashcard
for something wasn't enough to fully
acquire the word so you know I might
have a flashcard for something I'm to
learn the flashcard really well but the
first time I come across that word in a
book it still might not click it might
be like oh this word looks familiar but
I can't quite remember what it means and
this just is because memories can be
very context dependent so if you only
recall a word when you see a very
specific flashcard then that memory can
become dependent on that specific
context when you see it in a book in a
different context might not click
immediately but what I found is if I
looked it up when I was reading the book
and then had that aha moment of like oh
yeah I remember I have a flash card for
this I would only have to do that once
or twice for it's a pretty much
completely stick and for me to not
enough to remember it
I earn it I wouldn't yeah I would never
have trouble remembering up to that
point and the other one point I would
want to make is that my goal in this was
not to improve my active vocabulary
which is the words that I actually say
it was to improve my passive vocabulary
so the whole point of the flashcards was
to grow what I could understand then I
would get lots of input for that I would
understand and through that I wouldn't
actually get a sense of what words were
natural and what words were more formal
and not really appropriate for
conversation and I would have a be able
to imitate that myself so sometimes
Japanese people would look at my
flashcards and they'd see some rare word
that only is used in in like novels and
they say oh you don't need to know that
we never say that
oh I know I do need to know this because
I want to be able to read novels and
they use novels it's not a matter of
whether I'm gonna use it in a
conversation or not
right so two questions arise come to my
night right now so I'm gonna play the
devil's advocate here and when you say
you you said that you use our key you've
used your relied heavily on our key to
learn to learn Japanese so
the questions are have you done that for
Mandarin Chinese as well and the second
is what about all those people who don't
like using flashcards so what would you
suggest if someone said for example I
for one have never used Anki I know of
it and I've talked to some of my
students who use it but I wouldn't use
it just because I'm not used to I have
my own SRS system integrated in my own
language learning method so to speak but
yeah so the questions are have you done
it for Mandarin if you learned another
language would you still rely on Aki and
the second one the second one is if what
would you do what would you advise and
to use if if you can't use for whatever
you don't want to use onk you can't use
Anki yeah so yeah I have been using it
for Mandarin and it's been going pretty
well particularly because now I'm in I'm
incorporating a lot of audio onto my
cards and so I'll have cards where the
the front of the card instead of being a
text sentence it will be it actually an
mp3 from a Chinese TV show that I was
watching and there's a lot of tools that
allow you to do this I mean it's a
little complicated right now we're
working on streamlining the process well
what you can do if you really want to
take the time to set it up is you can
learn how to download videos from
Netflix put them into this program
called subs two SRS which will spit out
a non-key deck which has one card for
every subtitle line in the TV show with
the mp3 for that line you could put that
into Anki and then essentially when you
watch the show you can pause whenever
there's a sentence you want to learn
search that up and find it in your on
key deck and then move that into your
your main deck where you have all your
review cards and then you can have then
you can have audio on your cards and for
me this is important because since I
already know Japanese reading Chinese is
actually very easy for me because the
characters are almost the same and so
the real issue for me is listening
that's what I find the really difficult
part of Mandarin Chinese and so I'm
trying to test myself on the listening
by just having just the audio on the
front trying to understand that and then
I'll have the the characters on the back
and it yeah it's been going pretty well
for me I mean it's still slow cuz my
Mandarin is hard but I I yeah I find it
especially useful given that
I'm not spending nearly as much time on
Mandarin as I was when I was focused on
Japanese because you know I have a job I
do other stuff but Korps what uncle owes
me to do is even if I only spend you
know half hour 2 hour a day on it then
that's it's still gonna allow me to
maintain whatever I've learned I'm not
gonna backslide by forgetting things
because it's gonna at least guarantee I
remember 90% of what I've learned so
that's been going pretty well but as to
your other question about people hating
Hong Ki like this is definitely a thing
some people just seem to be allergic to
Oggy
it's just it's just not for them and I
would say that like migrator language
learning methodology is that the most
efficient way to learn a language is
combining mass exposure with the right
amount of conscious study and my
preferred form of conscious study is
Anki but if you have a different
preferred form I think that's totally
fine and ultimately you're you're still
falling into the overarching structure
of how I think you should approach a
language so in a way Aki's my preferred
way it worked well for me I think it
works well for people with my
personality type who like to be very
methodical they like how you know it
gives you statistics that show you how
how much stuff you learn but if you have
a different personality type then yeah
it might not be for you and I think even
just instead of spending a half an hour
a day on Anki maybe you could just spend
a half an hour a day like actively
reading texts and looking up the words
you don't know and being deliberate
about that and that ultimately can
probably have a similar effect or you
know Steve Kaufman has his system linked
which is a different way to kind of
incorporate active study or active
learning with your immersion and I think
that can work well for different people
as well so I don't necessarily think
that monkey is a one-size-fits-all
solution although I think there are some
very particular issues with Anki that
tend to deter a lot of people and yoga
and I are actually trying to work to
improve on these issues by creating
add-ons so for example one of the
biggest problems with Anki is that in
order for it to really work you have to
do it every single day because on keys
is gonna tell you every day what cards
you have to review that day and if you
don't review them that day then you have
double the reviews the next day so what
happens is a lot of times people get
busy they miss a day they get sick for
something and then the next day they
have double their reviews they don't
have enough time to do double and so
then they kind of just end up going
further and further into Anki debt and
then they end up just dropping it and
I've used to experience this all
time it's a huge source of stress that
you could never take a day off never
take a vacation and so we recently
created an add-on for Anki that we call
the vacation add-on that has a bunch of
features such as it lets you set days of
the week that you want to study and
weights that week that you don't want to
study so if you never want to study on
the weekend then unki will schedule
cards around that so you don't have to
or if you get sick and just have to take
a day off on the spot
then it will reorganize your your cards
so that with minimal harm to the
efficiency of the algorithm you can do
that or you can say oh in a couple
months from now I'm going to take a
two-week vacation and I'm not gonna do
any review so starting from pretty early
on it will not schedule or reviews in
there so I think these types of
improvements to Anki can make it more
accessible to people who have you know
normal lives things like that great
great answer now let's talk about kanji
so I've heard someone say actually not
multiple times people say that ask me
how many countries do you know you know
that's like the measure for my prowess
in Japanese was the number of conscious
that I can draw or so I got multiple
questions about countries first of all
do you think that it's important to
learn kanji from the very beginning
we're better to focus on the language
you know through transcript or maybe
using little mangy and can you like
handwrite not just type because nowadays
you know a lot of a lot of Japanese or
Chinese can they can type it sometimes I
forget about the most complex characters
and 3/3 is it worth learning to
handwrite because you can always
recognize and and type and forth let's
see if you remember for questions and
forth you said before that already
speaking Japanese and already
recognizing and understanding and
knowing conscious helped you with
reading a Chinese but don't you think
even if the sometimes of pronunciation
it actually comes from you know it
they're similar they're different but
similar in a way because the did it help
you or did it confuse you when it comes
to you already know a language you see a
cop you see a character a
cymbal and in your mind that symbol
represents both the meaning in Japanese
which is encoded in your brain as the
sound and then in Chinese you have
another language that comes later
because you learn it later and then you
have that other meaning and that outer
sound so on the one hand it's easier if
you understand the meaning of the
sentence because you recognize the
meaning of the conscious but doesn't get
it in the way when it comes to you know
speaking or recognizing or encoding that
information and in the new in the new
code that is Mandarin Chinese
I don't need to remember how many
questions I asked you but if you
remember yeah I think do you recommend
learning kanji right from the start
yes and so the way that I learned
Japanese in the way that I generally
recommend that we generally recommend
people to do it at the mass immersion
approach is to learn kanji at the start
but I think you could come up with other
formulations of the the overall process
where you would first focus more heavily
on the spoken language and then learn
their written language later on well I
think this is inherently more difficult
because it's just easier to learn from
text than from pure audio and you can
learn from transcription but I don't
know how many good resources that really
are for doing that and so it gets a
little bit impractical I think but you
you can do it and there are definitely
people who just go to Japan and they
become fluent in this book and language
itself learning how to write but the
thing is when you learn kanji you're
kind of opening up this opening the door
to this huge set of interconnections
within the language because there's
there are many kanji that all share the
same reading but they all have different
meanings and so when you learn a kanji
you realize oh like some were some
characters that have the pronunciation
su have this meaning of like
communication and so then every time you
learn a word that has that that su and
that communication you draw the
connection of like oh yeah it's the same
su as that other one so it helps you
keep track of morpheme it's kind of like
roots and stems in English and so I
think in a way in the long term although
in the short term it can be a real
challenge because you have to learn all
these characters it's hard in the long
term it makes things a lot easier
because if you learn a word that
consists of characters you already know
it's almost
effortless to learn the word because you
can guess them the meaning and the
reading or so I think yeah unlocking the
door to the phonemes of Japanese through
kanji is gonna be best path in the long
term especially because a lot of words
that are that are made up of kanji that
have the own Yomi reading this might be
hard to follow if you're not already a
little bit familiar with Japanese but
the characters and Japanese they have
two different sets of readings the onio
Mian the kunio me tsukuyomi are come
from the original spoken Japanese
language and the own Yomi are borrowed
directly from Japanese from Chinese that
a Chinese pronunciations and so there's
a lot of words with that Chinese
pronunciation that kind of sound there's
a whole many many words that sound very
similar to each other because they took
the [ __ ] the Chinese language and they
forced it into the Japanese phonetic
system and so a lot of information was
lost because Chinese probably had tones
back in the day they had more vowels and
and things like that and so there was
information loss when they would borrow
the pronunciations put them into
Japanese so now there's a lot of words
that just sound like super similar like
if you just look up cold chill in the
dictionary there might be over 15
Japanese words that are pronounced
exactly the same and if you don't know
the characters then it's really hard to
keep track of all the different words
because of this so in a way the there's
words that sound artificially similar to
each other in Japanese because they're
borrowed straight from an entirely
different language and so because of
this I think you're at a really big
disadvantage without kanji and was the
second before for God as kanji from the
start didn't handwriting like is
important or hand right is it worth it
well you just were addressing this and
then difference between Chinese and wall
if you got confused by knowing japanese
kanji when you tackled
mandarin chinese yeah and so so I can
write beautifully hand right can you do
that I hand right okay I used to be
better at it I don't really practice it
anymore
but I used to practice it more and I
mean I don't really have good
handwriting in any language but but I
was okay I get right I could write it a
lot of stuff at one point I can still
still I'm I could still survive if I I
don't like you know Phil
document by hand but I'm much better at
reading and over time the how much
emphasis I place on being able to write
it out by hand has continued to decrease
just because it's not really practical
there's almost no situation in real life
where you have to be able to write out
anything by hand I don't even write
things out in English almost ever I keep
notes digitally and so in a way it's
kind of just a party trick like honestly
like it's cool that you can write him
out you can impress Japanese people and
it will be useful when you have to if
you're living in Japan you have to fill
out some paperwork but in practical
terms on those few times where you
actually do have to fill out paperwork
you could just look them up on your
phone and copy them out so as long as
you can read them and as long as you can
type them and typing Japanese doesn't
require you to be able to write them out
you type phonetically essentially so all
you have to do is and know how the words
pronounced and be able to recognize it
then you're really fine and like like
you mentioned even Japanese natives are
getting worse and worse at writing out
the characters because you know if you
don't practice something then you're
gonna get worse at it so so do you think
it's worth it or it's not worth it
depends depends on that I think for I
think for most people it's probably not
worth it but some people they just
really love the characters and are
really passionate about them and just
want to be able to write them up by hand
and for those people I say yeah I
definitely go for it there's there's no
reason not to but for most people it's
it's just not gonna be worth all the
time and effort that it takes to do that
makes all sense so let's talk about
Mandarin Chinese and Japanese so did
that confuse her so it helped you in
confused or just helped was it
beneficial there's there's definitely
like a little bit of confusion like when
I first started learning Chinese and
even now what will happen is that like
there'll be certain characters where
I'll learn the Chinese reading of it and
I'll get very familiar like you know
there's the the like the character that
is just the possessive particle and so
in Japanese that has a it's pronounced
techie and it means something completely
different
early on I learned that okay it's
basically like the no particle in
Japanese it's the possessive particle as
pronounced like duh and so when I would
try to read Chinese subtitles I would in
my head I pronounced all the words that
exist in Japanese as Japanese but then I
pronounced just the dull as duh so I
might say look you know like like cue
Goku Doug Engel or something like that
so it was in my head it was funny
so as I learned more and more Chinese I
would in my head when I would be reading
Chinese I've replaced the Japanese
pronunciation with the Chinese
pronunciation and there there is some
confusion where I've noticed now that
I've been studying Mandarin more I'll
like my computers in Japanese still so I
remember the other day I was on like a
Google Doc and I looked at one of the
one of the options at the top and the
first reading that came to mind was
Chinese reading because it was the same
word in Chinese then I'm like oh wait no
this is Japanese though and so in a way
there's like two modes in my mind that I
have that you do have to kind of
separate them and they can get kind of
confused but I'd also notice that
because even within Japanese the same
kanji can be read many different ways
and there's even words that have many
different meanings and so as you and I'm
sure this is the case in every language
and so as you reach higher levels of
fluency your brain naturally becomes
able to determine what reading it's
going to be based off the context what
meaning is gonna be based off the
context and so I feel like just through
learning my Japanese my brain kind of
understood the concept that you know you
just a character is not a character you
can't just assume that it's always gonna
be the read the same way or the other
way and it's used to using context to
determine which it is out of many
possibilities so I feel like that Karen
stood over with Chinese and it kind of
understood like okay so this is a new
context called
Chan Chinese and so if I'm in this mode
I'm in this context and I have to go to
a different set of knowledge then if I'm
in the Japanese mode and there are even
words that they look the same in
Japanese and Mandarin but they mean
totally different things and they're
pronounced totally different ways like
one example is like team - and I'm
probably my pronouncation manner is
probably awful but it basically means to
understand or to be clear and in
Japanese that same character is read say
soul and it means to be like pure you're
like like a young woman or something is
like pure and innocent and so those mean
two totally different things and they
sound totally different but when I'm
reading Chinese because it happens to be
a very common word in Chinese my brain
automatically knows that goes to the
Chinese reading the Chinese
understanding because it's just already
developed the ability to know okay in
this context it's this and then when I'm
reading Japanese it's the other one
so generally there's four words that I'm
comfortable with my brain eventually
develops that ability to keep them
but there definitely is elite is you
know some leakage going over in both
that is a is a little bit worrisome and
I feel like once I get to the point
where I'm I'm spending even more time in
Mandarin there definitely could be a
little bit of confusion here and there
but I guess that's just par for the
course great thanks for the answer very
very thorough one last question before
we finish was about Mandarin Chinese and
I was just wondering how do you train in
speaking that is what what did you do
with tones because in my experience I've
seen that they actually in China and
across the entire world they tend to
teach tones backwards as they get a
habit of doing foreign language right in
general so they teach the individual
tone and then you have to remember the
single tone and then you have to
remember that the word has two syllables
and then you have to put it together
which makes it a you know a disaster for
your brain or the cognitive load you
have to think about the meaning of a
sentence so to say a very easy sentence
that takes centuries um I wonder since
you have such a profound awareness of
the mechanics and dynamics of language
learning in particular Japanese did that
help did that knowledge this awareness
that you have helped you in getting the
training right when it comes to acquired
tone so what what is it that you do what
is it that you've been doing and what is
it that you would advise to a person
approaching Mandarin Chinese for the
first time so a total language for the
first time or an Asian language for the
first time yes totally so I think that
Japanese helped a ton and ultimately I'm
still definitely don't consider myself
an authority on Chinese because I'm
still not very good yet so gotta take it
all with a grain of salt but um just
start with with Japanese so one thing
about pitch accent like the thing with
pitch accent Japanese is that there's
not a lot of education of or resources
about it because generally it's not
taught in Japanese classes and generally
Japanese people aren't very aware of it
consciously it's entirely unconscious
and automatic for them so when you go
and read about a resource and [ __ ] in in
pitch accent I think it's also a little
backwards just like in the way that the
Mandarin tones are generally talk so the
big insight that I had learning pitch
accent that that I had to come to on my
own because no one
told me is that ultimately it's not
really about the rise and the Falls what
it's really about is that for each pitch
accent pattern in Japanese there's four
basic patterns they each kind of have an
archetypal sound to it like there's the
hey bond pattern that just has this
eerie flatness to it like nihongo and
then there's the Tama Dhaka pattern that
has this release of energy at the top
like gene SID and sometimes and so
basically yeah each pattern has this
archetypal kind of ring to it just like
how even if a trumpet and a flute pate
flick play the same melody you could
tell which one was a trumpet and which
one was a flute and so you know when
people speak really fast
sometimes the it doesn't actually follow
the strict rules of when it's supposed
to go up and when it's supposed to go
down and so you can't really hear it and
this is why a lot of learners are like
how is it possible to hear this pitch
accent it's like way too fast and too
blurry but the thing is the archetypal
sound pattern is still there even if the
strict rise and Falls aren't and so I
think it's the same thing with tones
where you know each you know the more
what I consider you know the more
helpful tone resources they teach you
tone pairs right so each tone pair I
think has a certain ring to it a certain
sound to it and so it's less about
hearing like the exact wave pattern and
more about teaching your brain to
identify which pattern you're hearing
which kind of is archetypal you know
melody are you hearing and once you
train your brain to hear that and notice
that so that every time you you listen
to Chinese you can't help but notice it
that that pattern is happening then when
you start to speak you're it's it's not
really gonna be a matter of doing the
math in your head it's just gonna be a
matter of it's supposed to sound a
certain way and just like how if you're
singing you can hear if you're off tune
it it will just be like that so just
like how I was talking about pitch
accent it's about first getting enough
conscious knowledge to know what to
listen for
but then training yourself to actually
be able to hear it just through lots of
paying attention then you'll be able to
develop an intuition for what it's
supposed to sound like once you know
what it's supposed to sound like
intuitively then you can just guide
yourself to the right the right tone the
right you know make sure that you're
nailing it all just cuz it'll just feel
wrong when you're wrong so - you do
agree with me that learning the single
tone of each syllable and trying to
repeat it as kind of you know like yeah
I mean I think that at the beginning
you're not gonna be able to hear
so perfect that's why it for me I'm I'm
still just focused because I'm applying
my own method at first I'm just focusing
on understanding before speaking so I
don't even have to really worry about
producing it but I think the problem
with producing it is you're not gonna be
able to hear it you know like you can
imagine a student with Chinese working
with the native speaker they're saying
it over and over and they're like no not
like this like this and the person is
like getting better but to them it all
sounds the same they can wake up
tomorrow and then they forgot everything
they learned so they don't hear it you
know it's just like how humans can't
hear the the frequency of the the dog
Bell so I think the first that was to be
is you got to be able to hear it or you
have no shot of producing yourself and
that's gonna happen through a lot of
listening but you have to listen in the
right way because your brain might
ignore it if you don't really hone in on
what you're supposed to be hearing it's
not just about what you hear it's how
you how you listen it's not just about
okay I'm just gonna listen to Chinese
I'm gonna learn it's it's really it's a
very good point how you listen makes
hold of that and there's a go on uh just
one last point to make go into a little
bit more detail I think that ultimately
the mechanism of improving at anything
is trial and error so if we just think
about the process of getting better at
shooting free-throws right you shoot the
free-throw you aiming for the for the
basketball to go in the hoop and if you
miss you your brain sees how far off you
were and then instantly does a little
calculation of what you should do
differently next time if you were too
far to the to the left you're gonna try
to throw a little bit more to the right
and you could imagine that if you were
shooting free-throws with your eyes
closed and you never saw where the ball
landed you would never improve because
you wouldn't be able to you wouldn't be
getting any feedback on how well you're
doing and so I think that the same
principle applies with hearing things
like tones where first you you know
maybe you learn the most common 100
words you learn roughly how the tones
are supposed to work and you learn which
word is which tone then you you try to
hear it and when you hear that like me
how it's like can you hear that if the
tone went up and down if you heard it
and you you heard the tone then you tell
yourself like oh that was it and if you
didn't then you know oh I didn't hear it
and so you are providing yourself with
the feedback that's gonna allow you to
improve and that's why if you just
blindly listen you might never pick it
up because you're not creating that
feedback loop of trial and error I agree
fully agreed and I think it's a trial
and error process is really important
and I think that one word that people
should ban in language learning and
I think in general in life is perfection
that we were not perfect we're gonna
make a lot of mistakes we learn from
mistakes so this trial and error process
is all the more important when it comes
to acquiring a language you know it tend
to think that we have to get things
right immediately but that's impossible
in language or anywhere anything else
for that matter that's that's impossible
matt has been an amazing interview thank
you very much a one less thing that I
wanted to ask you you said that you will
you had I want to know I want to know if
you have some more precise informational
resources that you can point to when it
comes to pitch accents so you say that
you've you've dealt maybe maybe if you
don't have it at the drop of a hat to
say we add anyway I'll add more
information and links below but if you
have anything that comes to mind when it
comes to pitch Jackson because I found
something back in the day and I can't
remember
I try to look because I'm also
interested in this kind of analytical
understanding and delving into this so
if you have anything now or later please
let me know and I'm just gonna put it in
the description box so that yeah yeah
totally right now there's a southern
youtuber dogon who is really fluent in
Japanese and he makes videos in Japanese
in English and he created a phonetics
basically yeah phonetic series talking
about phonetics in Japanese and he goes
really in detail and pitch I'm sending
as many lessons talking about it and
they're not they're not for free you
have to subscribe to his patreon but I
think it's just ten bucks a month and
you can get access to all the lessons so
right now like I think that's that's the
best resource out there I want to
eventually make my own cuz I think I
could put my twist on it that would be
helpful but right now I think it's
probably the best resource out there you
definitely should it would be a great a
great product
okay met where tell people where they
can find your your website and yeah yeah
so you can learn more about the mass
immersion approach at mass immersion
procom you can also check out my youtube
channel matt verse japan and also on
twitter at Matt first Japan and we'll
put everything in the description box
Matt thank you very much there's been an
amazing interview and I'll see you soon
here on YouTube
awesome sounds good yep had a great time
thanks so much yeah right
you